yo if you'd like to support me in this
channel move University in creating more
video tutorials then please consider
making a financial contribution on my
website move University comm thank you
and enjoy the video
okay so enzyme inhibition
non-competitive inhibitors again we've
talked about them but I want to be more
complete in this video so enzyme free
enzyme binds substrate gives you the
enzyme substrate complex which can go
towards enzyme and product now where
does a non-competitive inhibitor come
into play with this well a
non-competitive inhibitor is going to
find that a site other than the active
site so of course the substrate binds at
the active site right square shapes
where active site here that I've drawn
for simplicity but this house shaped
sort of site is for this non-competitive
inhibitor inhibitor and C and C
non-competitive now you'll notice here
that the free enzyme and the enzyme
substrate complex can both get in a
non-competitive inhibitor attached to
them and that's because the
non-competitive inhibitor binds at a
site other than the active site right
this substrate can bind here right to
the free enzyme to form the enzyme
substrate complex but that doesn't
matter when it comes to the
non-competitive inhibitor the
non-competitive inhibitor because it
binds here that site as long as that
sites open is something they're impeding
this non-competitive inhibitor going
there then it combined the free enzyme
to form the enzyme inhibitor complex or
it can bind the enzyme substrate complex
to give the enzyme substrate inhibitor
complex which of course cannot proceed
towards enzyme a product even though the
substrate is bound there this inhibitor
is stopping this enzyme from being able
to convert the substrate into product so
you'll notice down here that if the
enzyme inhibitor complex forms this
substrate can come in and form the
enzyme substrate inhibitor complex so as
a good hopefully a good visual now let's
look at it in a different way so this is
basically the same representation just
without the picture so basically the the
non-competitive inhibitor
I NC can bind to either the free enzyme
or the enzyme substrate complex the
enzyme substrate complex and why is that
well again because the binding site for
the non-competitive inhibitor is
elsewhere elsewhere on the enzyme it's
not the active site it's not like a
competitive inhibitor doesn't bind at
the active site so whether or not the
substrate is bound is irrelevant to this
non-competitive inhibitor now does the
affinity for the substrate change why or
why not well the answer is no because
the substrate can still bind to the
enzyme when the inhibitor is bound right
so we can see that here in this in this
reaction that I'm gonna sort of circle
in green this substrate can can bind the
enzyme inhibitor complex or if it is
mined the enzyme right to form the
enzyme substrate complex so the the the
affinity has not changed and then thus
the km remains unchanged right I kind of
covered up the are there let me try that
again remains unchanged the km stays the
same so now the question is can the
reactions still reach the maximum
velocity why or why not the answer here
is no and I didn't type more words in
green here because it's a little bit
kind of crazy to explain what's
happening here is that the v-max
actually cannot be reached so the v-max
ends up decreasing the v-max decreases
why why is that though let's imagine
this the enzyme and substrate are
supposed to come together to make the
enzyme substrate complex which can
proceed towards free enzyme and product
that's supposed to happen uninhibited if
you add this non-competitive inhibitor
what's that going to do well that's just
it mean it can either take free enzyme
away to make the enzyme inhibitor
complex or it could take the enzyme
substrate complex and turn it into the
enzyme substrate and hit
inhibitor complex which of course cannot
proceed towards enzyme and product so
what's happening is that these
inhibitors are coming in and they're
basically they're basically depleting
the amount of effective enzyme substrate
complexes right so enzyme and substrate
were initially coming together at a
certain rate you know producing this
enzyme substrate complex and going to
these products but when we add these
non-competitive inhibitors they're
basically just you know pulling pulling
that away they're depleting that at a
certain a certain rate so this enzyme
substrate complex cannot form as quickly
and you know perform as effectively as
it could before so it's not going to be
as fast at creating these products and
thus the v-max decreases so how does
this look on a hyperbolic graph so we
just said that the km stays the same and
the v-max decreases so here in yellow
for no inhibitor uninhibited we've got
certain v-max up here at 100 and and
I've drawn here with the pink
non-competitive inhibitor I've just
drawn the v-max to be at at 50 it
doesn't necessarily have to be there um
I've just I've just drawn that here I
mean it depending on how much inhibitor
you add that can vary but I've added
enough non-competitive inhibitor to get
it so that the v-max drops to 50 so the
v-max here drops this enzyme is not this
enzyme is not as not capable to of
reaching that v-max anymore so now v-max
over 2 for the yellow for the yellow
reaction is at 50 right v-max over two
because it's v-max is 100 so it has a
certain km down here right at half that
v-max it has a certain substrate
concentration that's equal to the km for
the pink one v-max is 50 so it's v-max
over 2 is 25 be max over 2 is 25 so that
there a substrate concentration is still
at that same km it takes the same
substrate concentration to reach half
that v-max so the km is unchanged this
km is the same for both the inhibited
and uninhibited reactions inhibited and
uninhibited enzymes how does that look
on the line for Burk plot well the the
yellow line of course is the uninhibited
graph and the pink line is the inhibited
graph with the non-competitive inhibitor
so we notice that the x intercept here
stays the same and that makes sense
because the x intercept is equal to
negative 1 over the km and the km did
not change so the x intercept should not
change but we do see that the y
intercept changed so here the y
intercept of the uninhibited reaction
will call that y-intercept 1 and y
intercept 2 will be the pink one so we
see that the y intercept went up why is
that
well the y intercept is equal to 1 over
the v-max and the v-max decreased so if
the v-max decreased the y-intercept is
equal to 1 over the v-max if the v-max
is now a smaller number if we divided by
a smaller number we get a bigger number
so the y-intercept is now larger or
higher up and that makes sense the pink
lines intercept up here is higher up
then the intercept down here so so that
explains this difference in the
y-intercept
in addition the slope changed right km
stay the same that didn't change but the
v-max decreased so again we're dividing
by a smaller number the slope equals the
km over the v-max for dividing by a
smaller number now the slope is going to
get bigger
so the slope increase here
and we can see that right the rise over
the run for the pink line is clearly
larger hope that video is helpful thank
you for watching yo if you found that
video helpful then please be sure to
like comment and subscribe for more
content and if you know anybody you
might find this video helpful then
please be sure to share it with them
thank you and happy studying